(piano music)
- Yeah, I don't know, I mean,
we haven't really talked about it yet.
- You've been dating Rachel for how long?
- A year.
- Ten months.
- You have been dating
this girl for a year,
and you still haven't had the love talk?
- Love talk? Look, she's great, okay?
I'm just not a big love guy.
- The fuck's a love guy?
- [Man] The fuck is love talk?
- What is it?
- Hey, why are we giving
Derek a hard time?
What's goin' on?
- 'Cause he's dead inside.
- Look, okay, let's ask you.
How long do you go in a relationship
before you tell your
partner you love them?
- Derek has been dating
this girl for over a year--
- Under ten months.
- And he still hasn't told
her that he loves her.
- Have you ever told a girl
that you love her before?
- Yeah.
(slow piano music)
- Well that wasn't Rachel.
- But at least we know
he's not dead inside,
he has a heart.
He's a little cold right
now, but he has a--
- I just don't understand how you could be
with a person for a year and
a half and not love them.
- I never said I didn't love her.
We just, I just haven't said it yet.
- Has she said it to you?
- Kind of.
- What do you mean "kind
of," what does that mean?
- Hey, uhm, I kind of love you.
- Oh boy, she said it
first, that's not good.
That is not good.
- What is wrong with sayin' it first?
- The guy is supposed to say it first.
- Okay what if there's no
guy in the relationship?
- Oh yeah, my bad.
- That is a great point.
- Hurts.
- Just rewind, I'm sorry.
- Also, didn't you say it to Brian first?
- Like the knives are
gonna get any less clean
face down in the dishwasher?
- That's Just not the way
you load a dishwasher.
Period, fact.
- Who made that rule though?
- It's not even about the rules,
it's just, it's like
you don't listen to me,
like I love you and
you're just not listening,
or you don't hear me, or.
Fuck.
- You love me?
- Technically I said it
first, but it was an accident.
So it wasn't like I
planned it. Heat of moment.
But he said it back right after.
- I think you should
tell her how you feel.
She deserves to know.
- Hey guys I just wanna let you know
that it's Zack's birthday,
and I baked him some cookies.
- [All] Aw!
- Thanks Dev!
- I love you Devon!
- [Devon] Love you guys back.
- Love you. I love you girl!
I love cookies.
I just don't think Rachel
and I are there yet.
- You are somethin' else, Derek.
You are somethin' else.
- Drink your beer.
- I'm drinkin' it, you are somethin' else.
You play too much.
Cheap hoodie.
- You do play too much, general consensus.
- You can talk shit about me,
don't talk shit about my hoodie.
- No one did, literally, did you?
- I did a little.
- Oh I was thinking about me.